monsieur singh bonsoir bonsoir vous
allez bien oui merci vous aimez la
campagne j'adore la campagne j'adore
leur utilité de jaser avec légende
écouter leurs histoires et partager des
solutions
il ya des gens qui se posent la question
est qui nous pose souvent la question
pourquoi je voterais pour le npd si les
politiques ensuite sont semblables aux
libéraux on a l'impression que vous êtes
l'élu gauche parti libéral et il vous
volent constamment certaines de vos
idées cette campagne dix jours de congés
payés vous aviez proposé ça faire taxer
les banques mais ce trou d'où leur
proposez vous l'aviez proposé avant
comment vous vous différencie des
libéraux monsieur si la grande
différence effectivement c'est comme
monsieur trudeau c'est une des belles
paroles mais effectivement ce n'est pas
les actions concret qu'on a vu dans son
bilan dans pour nous ce n'est pas
seulement des belles paroles pour nous
c'est des convictions c'est des choses
qu'on veut changer
donc on en parle de la nécessité de
faire pire juste part des autres riches
pour nous c'est parce qu'on ne veut pas
que les pressions tombe sous les épaules
de monsieur madame tout le monde on veut
investir dans les gens donc pour nous
c'est vraiment différent et moi aussi je
suis différent j'ai vécu une vie
différent et je veux aider les gens
donnez moi un exemple très concret ya
des gens la maison qu'ils ont de la
difficulté pour l'achat de maisons pour
le logement se trouver un toit quelle
est la différence en ce que vous feriez
est ce que monsieur trudeau ferait une
bonne question donc ce qu'on a vu dans
les 600 que depuis justin trudeau est
devenu premier ministre on a la pire
bilan pour l'abordabilité des maisons
dans tous les pays de g7 c'est un bilan
assez pire dans ce qu'on veut faire
c'est de faire face au fait qu' on a des
compagnies étrangères qui
compétitionnait avec les canadiens pour
acheter une maison c'est quelque chose
qu'on va tout de suite arrêté justin
trudeau a eu six ans pour le faire mais
après six ans ne se range pas s'inspirer
comment stopper l'augmentation des prix
faramineux maison donc on a quelques
éléments de ce qu'on veut faire c'est
ainsi de mettre en oeuvre une taxe sur
les investissements étrangers dans le
secteur de achètent des maisons
deuxièmement on veut investir
massivement dans la fabrication des
maisons sociaux et abordables donc ça
c'est pour nous le logement abordable et
sociaux c'est primordial parce qu on est
vraiment dans un crise et on veut la
règle et je sais que vous en êtes à
votre deuxième campagne est ce que votre
analyse sur ce qui s'est passé au québec
a évolué comment se fait-il que vous
avez été presque rayés de la carte
la dernière fois je pense que les gens
ont fait leur choix et je respect ça
mais ce qu'on a ce qu'on a fait pendant
la pandémie on est montré aux québécois
et québécoises que avec le npd on est
aidé les québécois et québécoises
on est montés comment c'est que c'est
que la valeur d'avoir des néo démocrates
on a doublé la paix si on a augmenté la
salade subvention salariale et en
faisant tout ça on est sauvé des
millions deux emplois et on a aidé des
millions des gens mais monsieur legault
vous disais la semaine dernière vous
êtes trop centralisateur en sentez vous
dites moi les juridictions je veux rien
savoir de ça qui est plus d'argent c'est
ça qui est important et le fédéral doit
investir dans les champs de compétence
des provinces est-ce que ça c'est pas
plus difficile à vendre au québec si tu
peux nous immense de ça je crois
profondément dans la compétence des
provinces je connais ça j'étais juriste
j'étais avocat je comprends ça mais
quand j'ai parlé avec les gens qui ont
fait faire des grands défis les gens qui
ont perdu leurs proches dans les centres
de soins de longue durée quand je
regarde ces gens dans les yeux et
demandent des solutions et pour moi en
ligue 2 c'est quelqu'un qui cherche des
solutions pas qu'il cherche des excuses
aux et on a vu à plusieurs reprises
quand je pose des questions wayne justin
trudeau au monsieur trudeau il demande
des excuses au lieu de chercher des
solutions mais vous vous êtes d'accord
avec le fait que le fédéral
dépense dans des champs de compétence
des provinces m'y attendais absolument
mais on peut travailler ensemble pour
bâtir meilleur système comme on a fait
avec nôtre soins de santé c'était
leadership au niveau fédéral qui a dit
qu'on peut bâtir quelque chose qui est
meilleur d'un système privé et on a
réussi mais tout en travaillant ensemble
parce que c'est normal on doit la faire
dans un système fédéral on doit
travailler ensemble ce signe la dernière
fois je me souviens vous aviez dit moi
je ne pourrais pas travailler avec un
gouvernement minoritaire
du avec le chef conservateur est ce que
monsieur o toole aujourd'hui vous
pourriez travailler et appuyer un
gouvernement minoritaire conservateur
je comprends la question mais je veux
dire je suis dans cette à l'action pour
gagner dans le nez j'accepte le défi de
la question mais vous répondrai pas aux
normes mais je veux essayer de répondre
parce que je n'accepte pas une
hypothèque ou je perde d'amis je ne dis
jamais mais je peux dire c'est quoi la
question c'est essentiellement c'est
quoi ma position sur les conservateurs
donc je peux dire je pense que ça va
être mauvais pour les canadiens
canadiennes avec les décisions des
conservateurs je ne veux pas avoir un
premier ministre et un autre tube qui va
couper les financements pour les soins
de santé comme harper a fait et comme
justin trudeau a continué très bien
parlant de la vaccination parce que vous
vous prenez la vaccination obligatoire
des employés du gouvernement fédéral et
vous êtes le plus pressé en fait vous
voulez que ça se fasse très rapidement
la semaine prochaine comment ça peut
être mis en place je pense qu'ils ont
droit à la sphère permet mans parce
qu'on doit protéger la population je
pense des nausées ou des enfants battus
clément les enfants de moins de dix ans
qui ne peut pas se fait vacciner
eux-mêmes donc c'est important pour la
protection pour le bien commun donc on
peut la faire on doit travailler avec
les syndicats les travailleurs et
travailleuses mais c'est possible et
c'est nécessaire quand caen réalise
cette boue mais vous promettez quand
même des mesures disciplinaires la aux
récalcitrants oui on dit qu'on doit
avoir des conséquences pour les gens qui
ne ne seraient pas vaccinés ici
important parce que on sait que cette
mesure c'est important donc on reconnaît
les droits de la personne je suis
quelqu'un qui a défendu les droits de la
personne mais en même temps je respect
énormément les doigts collective les
doigts de bien commun et je vais
protéger les gens donc on peut trouver
une façon de y arriver mais est ce que
vous pensez vous que vous avez les
preuves que c'est la meilleure façon
justement de convaincre cette petite
minorité qui hésitent encore à se faire
vacciner parce qu'on voit les
manifestations on voit que ça polarise
quand même une petite partie de la
population j'ai peur de cette
polarisation c'était une bonne question
et j'ai vu l'impact et ça mais je veux
aussi souligner comme vous avez dit
c'est vraiment un petit population il ya
plusieurs personnes qui veut à travers
signer mais ils ont besoin dead mon chef
de cabinet m'expliquer que leurs voisins
a voulu être vaccinés mais il n'a pas eu
accès ou internet et ne savait pas
comment le faire donc elle a aidé et
puis elle a elle été vaccinées donc je
pense qu'on peut mettre plus d énergie
des résurgences sur aider les gens qui
veut être vaccinés mais qui ont besoin d
aide éducation c'est important mais on
sait pour faire face à cette pandémie
endroit très vacciner il voulait aussi
un passeport vaccinale fédéral mais le
québec a déjà le sien là on disait
monsieur legault dit vous êtes assez
centralisateur qu'est ce que vous faites
c'est ce nom en question d'avoir quelque
chose facile quand j'ai voyagé
dans les provinces atlantiques il y a
quelques semaines avant l'élection
c'était difficile est un peu complexe de
preuves de montrer la preuve qu'ils ont
été vaccinées on avait des documents
différents des applications différentes
donc si le goff et d'europe avoir un
passeport vaccinale pour voyager
étrangers pourquoi pas avoir une
document simple pour tout le canada si
on veut voyager au canada entre les pays
et entre les provinces et territoires
parce qu'on a des provinces qui dit non
on a des provinces qui dit oui mais
c'est facile d'avoir un document qui
peut fonctionner pour montrer la preuve
mais qu'est ce que vous faites avec le
québec déjà le sien oui mais c'est cool
c'est ça va continuer avec le garder oui
mais c'est notre outil pour aider les
gens si on voyage aussi on visite les
gens qui habitent en saskatchewan où on
n'a pas un passeport vaccinale qu'est ce
que vont faire si on veut voyager au
québec donc une document facile pour
rendre la vie plus simple facile pour
voyager mais si c'est une bonne idée
peut-être mais c'est peut-être pas
facile à appliquer la pcr e vous êtes
heures en faveur de la prolonger comme
le fait en ce moment le premier ministre
loue je suis en faveur de le prolonger
mais justin trudeau messieurs tueur doit
à couper l'aide aux gens et je pense
dans un quartier un vague de la cobi
19,6 la mauvaise chose à faire on sait
qu'il ya plusieurs personnes qui ont
toujours peur peur à perdre des emplois
où les gens qui ne peut pas retourner au
travail qui travaille peut-être dans les
secteurs de tourisme ou du des arts du
culture donc si tu jures un grand
problème pour plusieurs personnes notre
notre position en prespective c on sait
qu'il ya plusieurs grandes entreprises
canadiens qui ont pris l'argent public
mais qui ont exploité les systèmes on
doit s'assurer qu'il retire marge en
audio de couper l'aide aux familles aux
gens qui ne peut pas travailler ni
comment vous allez identifier ces
entreprises là on a quelques mesures
pour l'identifier à mesure c'est assez
public qui est il y a des centaines d
entreprises qui ont donné l'argent aux
actionnaires donc c'est complètement
public mais s'il peut donner l'argent
aux actionnaires ça veut dire qu'ils ont
réussi à avoir une grand profit donc
pourquoi ils ont obtenu d'argent public
ils doivent retourner cet argent pour
moi les grandes entreprises avec
beaucoup d'argent doit payer le juste
prix pas les gens qui travaillent
pendant les familles pas les personnes
âgées comme justin trudeau est lé a déjà
coupé l'aide aux personnes âgées aux
gens qui ont besoin de la paix si
heureux en même temps c'est un peu
difficile de changer les règles après
cool vous allez dire aux compagnies
l'argent vous avez fait on va vous
l'enlever mais le problème c'est siegen
une compagnie utilise cet argent pour la
mauvaise foi on doit dire et ce n'est
pas ce que on a vu du fer avec celle
d'argent c'était pour garder les emplois
c'était pour aider les travailleurs et
travailleuses et si vous ne les utilise
pas ça pour les bons raison donc on doit
dire non c'est mauvais vous devez leur
retourner pour investir dans les gens
qui en ont besoin vous voulez mettre fin
ou privés dans les centres de soins de
longue durée mais au québec a beaucoup
de résidences pour personnes âgées qui
fonctionne très bien et qu'ils n'ont pas
été plus visés que d'autres pendant sept
ans 2001 alors qu'est ce qu'elles vont
devoir fermer ce qu'on a vues et sait
quelque chose qui me frappe fort dans
cette pandémie je pense que c'était une
honte nationale si les faits que c'est
nos âges et nos personnes âgées
nos proches dans les centres de soins de
longue durée qui ont été les plus
frappés par la pandémie et nos forces
canadiens ont visité et ont aidé les
gens dans ces centres est ce qu'ils ont
vu les autres hommes et asie et ils ont
des ce sont des gens qui ont vu des
guerres tank pour moi je veux les aider
je pense que les profits ne pourra pas
être dans les centres de soins de longue
durée parce qu'on sait avec le profit
qui a quel argent vont aller aux
actionnaires aux exécutive et tu de
l'argent ne va pas pour les soins de nos
aînés et pour moi ce n'est pas
acceptable mais comment vous allez faire
ça vous allait nationaliser ces du
gouvernement fédéral qui deviendrait
propriétaire comment voulait fonctionner
non pas de tout ça mais on peut
commencer avec reverra c'est une
entreprise qui est le deuxième plus
grande à travers les pays et c'est
toujours propriétaire du gouvernement
fédéral effectivement donc on peut la
nationaliser mais pour les autres on
peut utiliser
les lois sur les santé canadiens comment
on l'a utilisé dans l'époque pour
changer les hôpital privé en public on
peut utiliser les mêmes outils pour dire
si on utilise notre argent public ça
doit aller seulement pour les soins de
nos aînés pas pour enrichir les riches
investisseurs et c'est ce qui se passe
maintenant et je veux l'arrêter donc
même celles qui fonctionnent bien
devrait fermer selon vous pas fermé
maintenant changé d'une but lucratif à
une but non lucratif parce que c'est
vraiment ces problèmes on l'a vu tu la
preuve dans les bus du créatif on a vu
les conditions les pires les plus
horribles et je veux éviter ça je veux
aider les gens j'ai parlé avec les
familles qui ont perdu leurs proches et
après l'epa a parlé avec eux ce n'est
pas en question de dire aussi n'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut faire on doit
trouver une solution
messieurs signe pardon environnement vos
cibles de réduction de gaz à effet de
serre sont celles du giec le groupe
d'experts son environnement et ils sont
plus ambitieuse que celle
du gouvernement trudeau du parti libéral
c'est 50% un peu comme les états unis
non c'est que c'est un pays pétrolier
alors comment il réalise comment
allez-vous y arriver je sais que ça va
être difficile donc je comprends ça mais
je suis toujours optimiste si on prend
les bonnes décisions on peut y arriver
donc quelque chose qu'on peut faire on
peut
investir dans la rénovation
écoénergétique saveurs réduire nos
émissions est aussi créé des bons
emplois on peut aussi investir dans le
transport en commun et électrifier le
transport et finalement on doit investir
dans l'énergie renouvelable et finale
finalement justin trudeau oui il a hélas
ni un prix sur la pollution mais elle a
exhorté les grands polars donc pour moi
ce n'est pas acceptable de faire ça on
doit faire face aux grands pôles war les
arrêter et aussi vous voulez mettre fin
aux subventions à l'industrie pétrolière
mais est-ce à dire que vous couriez même
des projets qui servent à la transition
énergétique la différence de ce qu'on
veut faire c'est la proche du
gouvernement libéral justin trudeau est
aussi des anciennes roulement
conservateur si des données des chèques
blanc aux entreprises et 10 ans vous
devez faire ça pour nous on doit avoir
des garanties fermes si on investit
d'argent ça doit être seulement pour
dire nos émissions pas pour aider les
entreprises qui augmente les émissions
dont pour nous c'est arrêter tout de
suite les subventions pétrolière et
seulement avoir des investissements qui
réduit les émissions donc des
investissements comme la restauration
des sites pétroliers je crois que c'est
un milliard 700 millions ces genres de
programmes qui seraient maintenues avec
ses 17 une approche qu'on appuie mais ça
doit être avec des garanties fermes sans
cette approche de la sefa qu'on a vu
dans le passé avec monsieur trudeau mais
aussi avec les conservateurs qu'est ce
que vous faites avec le pipeline
fairmont c'est une bonne question j'ai
déjà dit j'ai désormais prononcée contre
7 projets et si j'étais premier ministre
j'ai jamais acheté un pipeline je pense
que c'était une mauvaise décision mais
ce moment avec la décision doit
réfléchir ceux ci quoi exactement à la
position du canada mais ma position
était toujours contre oui parce qu'au
fond les investissements peuvent se
poursuivre ce sont des milliards de
dollars donc vous feriez une évaluation
avant de l'arrêter oui on doit on doit
évaluer la situation mais comme j'ai dit
je suis contre mais je vais faire une
bonne décision pour les canadiens il
fallut troisième lien entre québec et
lévis j
manifestement compter un délai très
court il y en a encore qui étudie alors
ça risque de vous coûter des voix dans
la région de québec seront mis un pour
moi c'est assez cohérent parce que je
dis clairement je suis pour
l'environnement je veux défendre
l'environnement et c'est un projet qui
n'aide pas à la lutte contre la crise
climatique donc jeunes un pin je ne le
suis pas mais on peut trouver les autres
projets qui nous aide dans la lutte qui
est vraiment un outil essentiel ouais
mais le gouvernement de monsieur trudeau
pense examens faits avant l'élection
examiner ce que patrice est faite à tous
le potentiel écologique ça devait
peut-être que couloir de transport en
commun est ce que ce sont des compromis
qui vous apparaît très acceptable avec
la troisième ligne ce qui est proposé le
nom je ne suis pas d'accord mais je suis
toujours ouvert à travailler ensemble
avec le québec pour trouver comment on
peut faire en sorte pour réduire nos
émissions pour investir dans
l'infrastructure qui nous aide dans la
lutte contre la crise climatique j'ai
reconnu j'ai parlé avec plusieurs
enfants des deux jeunes jeunes personnes
qui disent pour nous c'est la
primordiale question comment on va
garantie qu'on a un avenir ils ont des
inquiétudes et je veux répondre leurs
besoins et pour l'alberta comment allez
vous aider l'alberta à se sortir des
difficultés économiques oui ces temps
difficiles ont saisi vraiment autant
difficile pour l'alberta j'ai parlé avec
les travailleurs dans le secteur 2
d'énergie fossile c'est difficile parce
que leur travail est volatile de temps
en temps c'est bon et ça va bien mais il
ya beaucoup de temps où sa tombe et ils
ont des temps difficiles donc ce que je
veux faire pour ces travailleurs je veux
dire le la responsabilité de google et
de gouvernement s'étaient fortement
libéral mais quand je pense que je
critique mais la responsabilité du
mouvement dans mon cas ça va être un
gouvernement néo-démocrate
la responsabilité du gouvernement c'est
d'investir dans l'avenir pour le travail
pour les emplois qui restent et pour le
long terme donc je vais la faire je vais
aider les travailleurs on ne peut pas
avoir une approche pour faire face à la
clim ans qu'il a ça côté les
travailleurs donc on a une partie des
travailleurs on va les aider avez vous
l'impression que vous êtes plutôt comme
vous êtes plutôt à gauche que plusieurs
de vos propositions font peur davantage
les inspire confiance
non je pense qu' on est dans une époque
différents après ce qu'on a vécu dans un
point et demi je pense que les gens
pensent on a besoin des deux on a besoin
des investissements dans les programmes
sociaux je pense que plus que jamais les
gens sont ouverts aux idées comme
pourquoi les milliardaires ne paye pas
le juste pas pourquoi ils ont ils ont le
droit d exploiter le système qu'on
monsieur madame tout le monde paye juste
pas pourquoi amazon ne peuvent
virtuellement aucune taxe au canada je
pense que les gens sont ouverts un autre
approche qui dit les gens ne doit pas
payer la facture pour la relance ce sont
les résultats riches qui doivent payer
leur juste part ce signe j'ai posé la
question monsieur trudeau plus tôt on
lui demande un on a l'impression que la
dette c'est pas quelque chose qui vous
préoccupe beaucoup or il ya des gens et
des jeunes qui nous écrivent
régulièrement dans nous on veut pas être
pris avec le poids de cette dette là on
a l'impression qu'on lit votre programme
que les milliards ou si s'accumulent à
un rythme fou là vous dites toujours la
même chose oui mais on va faire payer
les riches est ce que c'est alice parce
que la dette est quelque chose qui vous
préoccupe oui bien sûr parce que je sais
les gens ils ont peur parce qu'ils ont
vu la même réponse du gouvernement des
gouvernements dans le passé soit ils
couplent aide aux gens où ils mettent la
pression sur les épaules des gens qui
ont déjà sacrifie si les deux approches
on est les seuls partis avec une
approche différente une troisième option
ça c'est de faire payer leur juste part
des autres riches mais c'est beaucoup de
choses on va mettre fin aux
échappatoires et ça peut nous donner des
milliards de dollars de plus pour est
venu on va faire payer leur juste part
des géants du web comme amazon et aussi
on va mettre un taxu les sur légion qui
ont des fortunes de plus de 10 millions
de dollars donc avec tous ces mesures on
peut investir dans les gens mais quand
les autres partis comme les libéraux
conservateurs par des crédits d'impôts
ou par des investissements il ne donne
pas comment ils vont le pays donc ils
vont faire deux choses soit coupé l'aide
aux gens dans les autres catégories où
mettre la pression sur les mêmes
personnes on a une pop proches
différents pour revenir aux premières
nations monsieur si on l'a vu à quel
point c'est difficile d'essayer de la
réconciliation d'essayer de faire des
ges l'eau potable tout seul les
conditions de vie les autochtones si
vous étiez au pouvoir c'est qu'elle
serait la mesure une mesure concrète que
vous pensez qu'il faudrait mettre en
place tout de suite pour améliorer la
vie des autochtones parce que tout ça a
l'air assez compliqué je pense que
l'enjeu qui frappe le plus fort et qui
est complètement inexcusable et le fait
qu'ils aient dans un pays du g7 à cette
époque avec les technologies qu'on a
c'est complètement inexcusable que les
communautés autochtones n'ont pas accès
à l'eau potable et justin trudeau a
promis de le faire il y a 6 ans elle a
dit que on va la faire jusqu'à 2028 21
et on a quand même une une partie mais
il dit qu'on ne peut pas réaliser si nos
promesses il a brisé sa sa promesse et
pour moi ce n'est pas acceptable parce
que on et vit dans un pays avec les
ressources avec l'archevêque la capacité
de régler ce problème je pense que c'est
fondamental qu'on assure que les gens on
accès aux l'eau potable de qui me disait
cocteau n'ont fait face des grands
injustice et c'est une étape important
ce n'est pas la seule tap mais j'ai
parlé avec les gens dénis squedin ya une
communauté avec les enfants qui a jamais
bu de l'eau potable dans leur vie et
après parler avec ses enfants j10 ce
n'est pas acceptable que ça continue je
vais la rêver mais c'est quoi c'est un
problème de d'argent ou de volonté c'est
un problème de volonté j'ai vraiment
réfléchi sur cette question parce que
quand justin trudeau a voulu faire
quelque chose là sauter dans la première
semaine de la pandémie et l'ami presque
milliards de dollars pour appuyer les
banques quand il ils ont demandé de
l'aide donc et pour faire lé grand chose
du gouvernement s'ils veulent donc je ne
pense pas que c'est une question de
capacité ou de d'argent je pense que
c'était une question de volonté et pour
justin tous aidé mais peut-être des
belles paroles mais pour eux c'était
jamais eu d'engagement concret pour moi
c'est un engagement concret y ait un
débat monsieur singh en forme à savoir
ce que ça devrait être un tj f grande
fréquence ou en tgv alors dans la
perspective donc d'une politique
environnementale quelle est votre
préférence où je pense que le train
conférence est quelque chose qu'on peut
réaliser plus vite et c'est essentiel la
communauté est déjà demandé ça je pense
que dans un pays assez grand que le
nôtre c'est essentiel d'avoir la
capacité d utiliser nos trains ne se
restreint plus plus et je pense que
c'est une très bonne chose à faire tout
de suite mais marc rêve c'est vraiment
d'avoir plus des investissements pour
avoir un train à grand vitesse aussi
c'est quelque chose qu'on peut réaliser
mais je pense qu'on doit commencer avec
les trois grands faits quand son
imposant de reculer moyens d'avoir votre
rêve de rien m j'avais cette rente aille
plus qu'on en parle c'est ça c'est ça
donc les gens ont besoin de quelque
chose tout de suite ah si on a un tronc
de plus grande fréquence je sais que les
gens va l'utiliser si ça fonctionne
c'est bien j'ai utilisé souvent les
trains c'est excellent mais le problème
s'il n'a pas beaucoup comme horaire et
c'est difficile pour les gens qui
veulent travailler dans une autre vie
pour avoir rendez-vous donc si on peut
avoir un train de plus grande fréquence
ça va vraiment changer la très belle aux
signes de pénurie de main d'oeuvre on à
part avec tous les chefs beaucoup
beaucoup de gens s'inquiètent
est-ce que ça passe par l'immigration ou
sinon une chose très concrète que vous
proposez là tu supportes l'immigration
ces huits utile nécessaire la formation
c'est toujours unity nécessaire je pense
aussi les gens veut travailler dans mon
avis les gens veut travailler ils sont
fiers de travailler
mais si les conditions de travail ou le
salaire de travail des papes n'est pas
bon les gens ont de la misère à
travaille donc pour moi c'est vraiment
les conditions de travail la coût de la
vie si on peut régler ça oui bien sûr
les gens veulent travail chaque mécène
bonne fin de campagne merci beaucoup
au revoir